[Music]
trying to put into words just how happy
i am i'm lauren zima here at Delilah in
Hollywood we are at the launch event for
celebrity jewelry designer Lorraine
Schwartz's new Eagle Eye bangles
collection so many celebrities are
walking into this party you seem very
happy with this man in your life I am
very good he was like gushing about us
but over the weekend and everything what
what is it about him that has you so
happy like why do you guys work so well
I think you know he and I come from very
similar worlds and so we have a level of
understanding for each other that I
didn't really get in past relationships
I knew him right away when I was excited
to show him off like when I wanted
everyone to know how amazing he is
because I've kept most American ships
pretty quiet and pretty secret in the
past but he's just so amazing I need
everyone to know all the time I can't
help but I am his and he is mine
all right and will there be any more
collaborations for you guys in the
future I don't know it's possible I mean
the record just what number one and
we're really excited about that and I'm
a huge fan of his music and I happen for
a really long time so you know it was
kind of a no-brainer when it came time
to write this song but um let's hope the
next one is another love song and not a
break outside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]